The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: So let me first
just remind you briefly
what we did in last lecture--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: --which was ages ago.
[LAUGHTER]
So we, say, quote unquote,
derived the AdS duality.
And then we also
described a little bit
to the geometry of the
Anti-de Sitter spacetime.
So there are two things
I want you to remember
about Anti-de Sitter spacetime.
You said, there's two
ways to think about it.
One is so-called
the Poincare patch,
is that, say, we have a
coordinate z or R. It depends
on your choice.
So for each constant--
z is equal to 0.
Add to the boundary of AdS.
So AdS have a boundary,
symmetric, yeah, so R squared.
So z goes from 0 to infinity.
And at z equal to 0, the
overall [? prefect ?] blows up.
So the spacetime become
bigger and bigger.
So this is what we will
normally call the AdS boundary.
And then when z become bigger,
then you go to the interior.
And then at each consonant z
the spacetime is [INAUDIBLE]
Minkowski space, say, our D
dimension in Minkowski space.
So this give you
an AdS d plus 1.
OK, so this gave
you an AdS d plus 1.
And so of each z [INAUDIBLE],
it's an AdS space.
So this is so-called
the Poincare patch.
And another way
to think about AdS
is so-called the global AdS.
In the global AdS, AdS
is just essentially
a [? sort ?] in the cylinder.
And it is a time direction,
which we call tau.
And then there's a radial
direction we call rho.
And then there's some
angular direction.
And then the boundary of
the surface-- for example,
you can write in this
global case as 1 over,
say R squared cosine squared
rho, say, minus dt squared
plus d rho squared plus sine
squared rho [? d ?] omega
squared d minus 1 squared.
OK?
And this rho, and
the angular direction
is this omega d minus
1, so d tau squared.
OK?
And then when [? rho ?] goes
to pi over 2, then the, again,
the overall
[? prefactor ?] blows up.
So at the rho power over
2, so this is the boundary.
So the boundary here is S3
times R. So SD minus 1 times
the time.
So it's just really a cylinder.
So here, the boundary
is the R1 d minus 1,
just the Minkowski
spacetime, OK?
So this is two way I want you to
think about the Anti-de Sitter
spacetime.
And also, yeah-- so
before we continue,
do you have any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just a short one.
So you draw a cylinder, But
the spatial part of that metric
is not precisely a cylinder.
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: I mean, the
spatial part of the metric
is not precisely [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: You mean the boundary?
AUDIENCE: No, I mean the
sine squared rho term.
That's a cylinder.
HONG LIU: Oh, I'm just
saying the topology.
I'm saying the topology is
[? a sorted ?] cylinder.
Yeah, the topology is
[? a sorted ?] cylinder, yeah.
Any other questions?
OK, good.
So also, let me remind you
this original definition
of the Anti-de Sitter spacetime.
So Anti-de Sitter
spacetime can also
be defined as a hyperboloid.
Hyperboloid in the d plus
2 dimensional Minkowski
spacetime.
OK, so this is the
AdS d plus 1 can also
be defined as
hyperboloids in the d plus
2 dimensional
Minkowski spacetime.
It's 2 time.
So it's a 2,d
signature with 2 time.
OK?
So now, let's talk
a little bit more
about the-- the last time we
talked about geometry of AdS.
Now, we talk about little
bit the symmetries of AdS.
So let's just further
that discussion, so d
plus 1 dimension of AdS,
Anti-de Sitter spacetime.
So I assume all of
you are familiar of is
the concept called isometry.
If not, it's very
easy to understand.
So isometry refers to
the class of coordinate
transformations, which
leaves the metric invariant.
OK?
And it's, say, if it's a
Minkowski spacetime, then
the isometry will the
Lorentz transformation
plus the translations, OK?
So that's the isometries.
And so for this
AdS, by definition,
the isometry would be SO(d,2),
because this is hyperbole
for AdS, because the AdS
is defined as a hyperboloid
in this d plus 2 dimensional
Minkowski spacetime with
signature (2,d).
And this hyperboloid preserves
the Lorentz transformation.
So the AdS, the symmetry
will be SO(d,2).
Just the Lorentz symmetry
of this embedded Minkowski
spacetime.
There's no translation
because this equation
breaks the translation.
OK?
Because this equation
breaks the translation.
So yeah, so you can see
immediately just from there.
But what we will
be useful later is
to understand how
this is refracted
in the so-called Poincare patch.
OK?
So let's talk about how
this symmetry is realized
in the Poincare
patch, which I will
use these z coordinates, which
I will use these z coordinates.
So first, they are translations,
which we can translate, say,
x mu to some constant.
So by x mu, I always
refer to using
these Poincare coordinates.
The x mu always refer
to t and the vector x.
OK?
So this is the--
so first, obvious,
there's a translation in
the t and x direction,
because that's independent
here [? in the ?] x.
And then this also
Lorentz transformation
in the x direction, because of
the dependence on the t and x
is just the Minkowski metric,
because each is [INAUDIBLE]
that Minkowski metric.
OK?
So this has d generators.
So this have 1/2
d times d minus 1,
because this is the
Lorentz transformation
in the d dimension.
And then, also, there's scaling.
So that metric, it's invariant
under such a scaling.
So just scale x
mu and z together.
And clearly, the
metric does not change.
So if you scale
z and x together,
then all the scaling cancels.
No, of course, this does
not change the metric.
OK?
So there's also scaling,
so this have one generator.
So the last isometry
in the-- it's
called special conformal
transformation.
The last image of
this space, which
is called the special
conformal transformation,
it's a little bit
more complicated.
Let me just first write it down.
Then I will try to give you
some intuition about it.
So the [? free ?] parameter,
so the parameter for this
transformation of
[? actor ?] b mu.
OK?
So I will introduce.
So the transformation
is the following.
z go to z prime equal to-- and
the x mu goes to x mu prime.
OK?
So b mu is just an arbitrary
constant vector, just constant
vector.
And so b mu squared,
so b squared is just
your standard b mu b mu.
Under the A square, it's defined
to be z square plus x mu x mu.
OK?
So you can check
yourself, requires
a little bit of effort.
You plug this transformation
into this expression.
And then you can show
that this is invariant.
OK?
So this have d
parameters, because b.
So the transformation
parameters,
they are the d parameters.
So they are d parameters here.
OK?
Because of the b mu.
So this transformation
can be understood
in a slightly easier
way, as follows.
It's as you will also
do this in your p
set, is that you can check.
So to understand this Special
Conformal Transformation,
so I called SCT.
First, you can check the
following is isometry,
something we call inversion.
It said if z goes to z divided
by A, so A is this quantity.
Oh, A, I think I'm having
some notation error, myself.
So I should call it
A, rather, A squared.
Sorry.
It doesn't matter.
I can also call it A
squared, but let me just
call it A. I think that one
would be [? A2. ?] Yeah,
that is [? A2. ?] So,
yeah, I could just
call everything A squared.
But to be consistent with my
notation on the [? notes, ?]
just let me call it A.
So you can also check that
the following discrete
transformation is
also isometry, so when
z equal to z divided
by A, and x mu
goes to x mu divided by A. OK?
You can check this is isometry.
So if you plug this
into this metric,
you find this [? leaves ?]
the metric invariant.
And this thing is
much easier to check.
But as you will
do in your p set,
and you can check yourself,
this discrete transformation
actually is not
part of the SO(d,2).
It's, in fact,
part of the O(d,2).
So if you calculate its
determinant, say the Jacobean,
actually find the
minus 1, rather than 1.
OK?
So this is not a proper
Lorentz transformation.
It's not a proper
transformation,
what we normally call the
proper transformation.
But however, if
you do this twice,
the minus 1 times
minus 1 equal to 1,
then you get the
proper transformation.
But, of course, if
you do this twice,
you just go back to itself.
You can check.
This is inverse of itself.
So this is like a
[? z2 ?] transformation.
But you can do
[? a slightly ?] [? trick ?].
Then you can show that
this special conformal
transformation is
given by an inversion.
You first do an inversion, and
then you follow the [? bad ?]
translation in b mu.
And then invert it back.
OK?
So even though you can check
that I squared is equal to 1,
well, now in the middle, you
have added the translation
in b mu, a constant.
And this is a symmetry.
And, of course, the whole
thing will be a symmetry.
But now, this is a
proper transformation,
because I have act I twice, OK?
So you can now check this
transformation is precisely--
if you do this, it's precisely
just that transformation.
OK?
So if you add all
of them together,
d will have d minus 1 d.
Then you can show actually
they form this symmetry group.
They form this symmetry group.
So altogether, you
have d plus 1/2 d times
d minus 1 plus 1 plus d.
Then that give you 1/2 d.
You can check yourself,
like 1/2 d plus 1 and d
plus 2, which is precisely the
number generated for that one.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the total here
that dimension, the d plus 1--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why like
even translation,
it only has a d
dimensional invariant.
HONG LIU: No, because this
depend on z, so the translation
[? in ?] z is not invariant.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Yeah, so that would be--
HONG LOU: Because
this depend on z.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HONG LIU: So if you translate
z, this is not the isometry
[? under ?] the metric changes.
So only the translation
t and x is a symmetry.
So that's why we only
do the translation x mu.
AUDIENCE: I have some questions.
HONG LIU: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So
conversion is isometry.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yes?
OK, so but inversion,
there's a [? release ?] not
in the SO(d,2)?
HONG LIU: Yeah, right.
AUDIENCE: So that
means the symmetry,
isometry [? work ?] [? with ?]
[INAUDIBLE] [? SO? ?]
HONG LIU: Yeah, yeah.
It's the standard story.
You have O. You can
have an O symmetry.
There's a discrete
part, which is O/ When
you're transformation,
you're changing the Jacobean,
whether your Jacobean
is 1 or minus 1.
You just actually
[? exactly ?] the standards
of the transformation in
the Minkowski spacetime.
In the Minkowski
spacetime, you can also
can see the [? site ?]
transmissions.
AUDIENCE: OK.
HONG LIU: Yeah,
just the same thing,
because this is just the
transformation in the Minkowski
spacetime of this
embedded space.
AUDIENCE: So in the
[INAUDIBLE] metric,
we also have a, like a--
determine [INAUDIBLE]
transformation.
HONG LOU: Exactly the same as
the standard Minkowski space.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: But discrete part
just like a [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Oh, no, it depends.
Yeah, in the old dimension,
yeah, in the 3 plus 1
dimension, just the
[? parity. ?] That's right.
In the 2 plus 1 dimension,
if we invert all directions,
then it's not.
Right?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there
an easy way to see
the special conformal
symmetry of the system?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Is there
an easy way to see
a symmetry from the metric?
HONG LIU: Yeah, you
just plug this in.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Well, I
mean, how do you
know that there is such
symmetry, [? complicated ?]
symmetries?
HONG LIU: No, just say
another way to understand
is to do this one.
So this inversion is a much
simpler transformation,
which you can easily
check [? its ?] isometry.
And then this procedure will
guarantee this is isometry.
[? because ?] each
step is isometry.
Good?
OK, so after talking
about the-- so
that concludes our very quick
review about the geometry
and properties of
Anti-de Sitter spacetime.
AUDIENCE: But maybe one
more quick question.
So since you said the isometry
[? bigger, ?] and so if you why
you only answer on the [? SO? ?]
HONG LIU: It's the same thing.
In Minkowski space,
we can also separate
the discrete transformations and
consider the continuous part.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
HONG LIU: Yeah, so it's
just exactly the same thing.
AUDIENCE: OK.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Certainly here, we can
consider the inversion too.
We just here, I'm
considering the part, which
connect to the [? identity ?].
AUDIENCE: OK.
HONG LIU: Any other question?
AUDIENCE: So is it true
that in some dimensions
the inversions
[INAUDIBLE] isometry?
HONG LIU: I think-- no, I
think actually more dimensions.
This is not.
In more dimension,
this is [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, it--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Inversion is always
isometry in any dimension.
AUDIENCE: But it's just that
the determinant [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: No, it's always
minus 1, any dimension.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Other questions?
Good.
So after talk about Anti-de
Sitter spacetime, now
we can talk a little bit
about the string theory
in Anti-de Sitter spacetime.
OK?
We can talk about string theory.
Now, let's talk a little bit
more about a string [INAUDIBLE]
the distance [INAUDIBLE].
This discussion is very
easy and essentially trivial
because we know very little
about this string theory
in Anti-de Sitter spacetime.
[LAUGHTER]
And so there's not
much to talk about.
But there are a few general
statements we can say.
So there are a few general
First is that both
AdS 5-- so we have
said that AdS 5 is the
maximally symmetric space
of negative curvature.
And we all know from your
really kindergarten years,
that S5 is the maximal symmetric
space of positive curvature.
So this combined
together is really
a maximally symmetric space OK?
So this AdS 5 times
S5, so AdS 5 times
S5 is a homogeneous space,
homogeneous spacetime,
maximally symmetric
homogeneous spacetime.
So whatever string
theory in this space,
it's-- so the only scale in
this space is the curvature,
curvature radius, and which
is the same everywhere.
OK?
It's homogeneous.
It's the same everywhere.
So essentially, R, so this R
will be just a single parameter
to characterize the curvature
of this spacetime, so
single number,
which characterize
the curvature of the spacetime.
So even the space
is not homogeneous,
and you have to specify
which place, which curvature,
et cetera.
But this is the maximally
symmetric space, homogeneous.
So a single number captures
the curvature everywhere.
So that means that in string
theory on this spacetime,
it's really just characterized
by the following dimensionless
parameter, so alpha prime
divided by R squared.
I mean, alpha prime is
a dimensional parameter.
But in the end, it's given by
the following dimensionless
parameter.
And only for any
physical process can
only this
dimensionless parameter
goes in, not separate
of them, because there's
no other scales.
i is the only scale, and alpha
prime is the only [? other ?]
scale.
And so for any physics, the
only dimension parameter
can come in is this one.
And, of course, there's
another dimensionless parameter
is the gs, is what we
call the string coupling.
So essentially, the
series is specified
by these two parameters.
OK?
And depend on what
you want, you can also
construct the Newton constant.
The Newton constant
can be expressed
in terms of gs and 1/2 prime.
So in type IIB
string, the relation,
so we are talking about type
IIB string, the relation
between the Newton
constant and the,
say, alpha prime and the gs
is given by the following.
So instead of a considering
these two parameters,
you can exchange gs
by Newton constant.
So you can alternatively
consider, say,
gn to the R to the power 8, or
alpha prime to the R squared,
or just characterized by these
two dimensionless numbers.
After your choice, sometimes
this is more convenient,
and sometimes, this
is more convenient.
So if you talk
about string theory,
work with the string theory
[? parse ?] [? integral, ?] et
cetera, then this
is more convenient.
But if you think
about the gravity,
then the Newton constant
appears naturally.
And then this become
more [? natural. ?] OK?
So the fact of the theory
is controlled by these two
dimensionless parameters.
AUDIENCE: The R is a constant R?
HONG LIU: Yeah, same R. It's
just the curvature radius
over the spacetime.
The whole spacetime, it's just
controlled by the single R.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
HONG LIU: Yeah, yeah, also,
implicit in the discussion
here, which is in the metric
where I wrote last time,
is that the
curvature radius here
is exactly the same as
the curvature radius here.
And so the single
curvature radius
characterizes the whole thing.
OK?
OK, good.
So this means that whatever
quantum gravitational theory
or string theory
in this spacetime,
you can consider q limit,
based on this 2 dimensionless
parameter.
So first is so-called the
classical gravity limits.
So this is the limit, which
the string coupling goes to 0.
So that means-- remember,
the string coupling controls
the [? loop ?] [? corrections ?]
over the strings.
And also, essentially, it's the
fluctuation over the spacetime.
And so the string coupling is 0.
And also, the alpha prime
divided by R squared goes to 0.
OK?
So this alpha prime divided
by R squared goes to 0.
So this is can be considered
as a point particle limit.
Because alpha prime
essentially characterize
so the [? sides ?] of a string.
And when the side of the
string is much smaller
than the curvature radius,
and then essentially,
it's a point particle limit.
So this is the standard
classical gravity limit.
So in this region, we
have classical gravity.
And you cannot tell that
those particles are strings.
They're just like
ordinary particles.
OK?
So similarly, so g string
[? to ?] [? 0 ?] can also be
considered as the limit.
The Newton constant goes to 0.
It's the same thing.
OK?
It's same thing.
And so in this region,
[? you ?] get classical gravity.
And more specifically,
in our case,
we get to have to be super
gravity, which we briefly
mentioned before.
So there's a lot of the region
is called the classical string
limit.
In this case, the alpha
prime divided by R
squared can be arbitrary.
Does not have to be small.
So in this region, than the
string [? G ?] [? fact ?] will
be important.
So you should be
able-- then that means
that the spacetime
curvature radius is
comparable to the string sides.
Then in this case, you can
no longer treat the string
as a point particle.
But we still take
g string goes to 0.
So that means that the
quantum fluctuation is small.
The spacetime quantum
fluctuation is small.
So in this case, you still
have a classical theory.
But it's a classical
string theory, rather than
a classical gravity theory.
OK?
Any questions regarding this?
So there's another--
something else?
AUDIENCE: No.
HONG LIU: So there's one
feature in this spacetime.
So this is altogether 10
dimensional spacetime.
There's one feature
of this spacetime.
It said S5 is a compact
space with a finite volume.
And AdS 5 is uncompact OK?
So normally, when you
have a compact space,
so it's convenient--
so S5 is compact.
So it's actually convenient
inside your situation
to express whatever, say, 10
dimensional field in terms
of-- yeah, it may be to
not express, to expand,
but in 10 dimensional
fields, in terms
of harmonics, [? inverse ?] 5.
OK?
Because there's a discrete
set of harmonics on S5,
you can always expand some
10 dimensional field on it.
So for example, if you
have a scalar field,
so supposing if you have a
10 dimensional scalar field,
say we have x mu.
We have z.
So this is AdS5 part.
And them let me call it
omega 5, which is S5 part.
Then you can always, say, so you
can expand these scalar fields
in terms of spherical
harmonics on S5.
OK?
Then what you get is you
get a tau field in AdS 5.
And then this are
spherical harmonics in S5.
OK?
And in particular, when you do
this expansion, than the higher
harmonics, they will
develop a mass, because
of the curvature of the S5.
So the lowest mode
will be independent,
say, of the
coordinate on the S5,
where the higher mode will
depend on the coordinate of S5.
And because of those
dependence, because
of the curvature of [? base ?]
5, they will develop a mass.
So the lowest mode
would be massless,
then they will be followed
by tau of massive modes,
controlled by the
[? size ?] of AdS 5.
OK?
So you can do this for any
field, any particular [? the ?]
metric.
So when you do
this, essentially,
only the massless graviton in 5
dimension will [? mediate ?] no
[? range, ?] say, gravitation
[? interactions ?] in AdS 5.
So essentially, so the
gravity, so at a long distance,
the gravity is
essentially 5 dimensional.
OK?
It's the same in 5 dimen--
because you can always
reduce on S5.
So there's a slightly
tricky thing here.
But it's only-- it's
that the size of S5,
the curvature radius
of S5 is actually
the same as the curvature
radius of AdS 5.
So there's not really a
hierarchy here in terms
of the curvature radius.
But there's still an
important difference.
These have infinite volume.
These only have a finite volume.
So these are compact.
These are uncompact.
OK?
AUDIENCE: But why the
gravity [? doesn't-- ?]
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: But why
the gravity doesn't
say this string [? S5? ?]
HONG LIU: No, it-- [INAUDIBLE]
[? this thing ?] radius--
this [? thing ?] S5.
But just as I said,
this is a compact part.
You can always do a reduction.
And then the higher graviton
mode will develop a mass.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
HONG LIU: Yeah, we
develop a mass, yeah,
even though that
mass is not very big.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if we applied
this to the real world, then
what would estimate for R?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: What's the
estimate of this radius,
this curvature for if
it's should be comparables
are of the original worlds?
HONG LIU: [INAUDIBLE]
the size of the universe.
AUDIENCE: But then
doesn't it mean
that we only should worry about
the mass of this compact mode?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Only on distances
much longer than ours?
HONG LIU: Yeah, yeah.
I mean, just saying,
at very large distance,
essentially is 5 dimensions.
But it's still-- you can
talk about the distance
scale, et cetera.
But here, R is the only scale.
It doesn't matter how
large is R. Everything
matches against R. R
provides your units.
AUDIENCE: Yes, but when
we talk about distances
shorter than R then--
HONG LIU: Yeah, if you talk
about a distance shorter
than R, it doesn't matter.
It's like a 10 dimensional.
It's like a 10
dimension [INAUDIBLE].
But AdS is uncompact, you can
go as much distance as you want.
I'm just saying, the
story is slightly tricky
because they have the
same curvature radius.
But I'm trying to
describe it in the spirit.
And also, mathematically,
you can always,
because S5 is uncompact,
you can always
do dimensional reduction on it.
And this provides
a convenient way
to organize fields, in terms
of 5 dimensional fields.
AUDIENCE: OK.
HONG LIU: OK.
So one thing we will
often use is, indeed,
just consider the dimensional
reduction of the gravity
to 5 dimension.
So if you have, say,
say suppose this is
Einstein-Hilbert action in 10d.
So this is AdS 5 part.
This is the S5 part.
So you have some 10
dimensional, so curvature.
So R is a [? rich ?]
scalar in 10d.
OK.
Now, suppose the metric,
suppose this considered
the lowest mode for the metric,
which have low S5 dependence.
And then you can just reduce
this to a 5 dimensional theory.
Gravity, so the
volume of the S5 part,
we are just
[? factorize. ?] Then
you have a 5 dimensional scalar.
OK?
And this b5 is just
the volume of S5.
OK?
5.
And now, we can absorb this b5
into downstairs, then define
or you factor your 5
dimension Newton constant.
5 [INAUDIBLE] Newton
constant, which
we are call G5, which is
defined to be GN divided
by the volume of the 5 sphere.
OK?
And the volume of the 5 sphere
is, essentially, just pi q.
OK?
And then, of course, there's
R to the power [? of 5th. ?]
So this is the quantity
we will often use.
OK?
So of the dimensional
reduction, in the end,
you get the action [? we will ?]
have the form 14 pi G5,
so 5 dimensional Newton
constant, say, [? d5x ?],
just AdS part.
And then you have the
gravity part of the action.
And then you plus many,
many matter fields.
So this is, the essentially will
be the structure of your action
when you do the
dimensional reduction.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Shall we have
matter fields in the S5?
HONG LIU: No, you
reduce everything on S5.
And once you have done that,
then S5 will disappear.
AUDIENCE: But when
we do, say, the R
is [? always ?] a constant, so
we can do the integral easily
in S5.
But if we don't have
some mass [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah, so
no, it doesn't matter.
So you can take-- this is a
standard story for [INAUDIBLE]
reduct-- a standard story.
When you expand around in this,
so this will go into here.
Then the only dependence
on the S5 part
will depend on those things.
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
HONG LIU: Then you just
can't integrate those things.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
HONG LIU: You can
always integrate them.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
HONG LIU: And they just give you
some integrals, some numbers.
It would just give
you some numbers.
And in the end, you can
always write the action
in terms of 5
dimensional action.
AUDIENCE: But that solution
is a classical solution
for the [INAUDIBLE] equation.
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
This is not a
classical solution.
I'm just doing an expansion.
It's just like doing
a Fornier transform.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
HONG LIU: This is expand
in terms-- in some basis.
No, have not done anything.
This just a
mathematical rewriting,
AUDIENCE: Mm-hm, OK.
HONG LIU: Yes?
AUDIENCE: But I think in terms
of expression for G Newton
into the affected-- don't we
have that this G5 is like G
squared alpha for the
[INAUDIBLE] [? divided by ?]
[? R to the 5th y ?] can put
[? a use it ?] to this alpha R
squared combination?
HONG LIU: Sorry--
AUDIENCE: Express G5 in
terms of GS and alpha prime.
HONG LIU: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And [INAUDIBLE].
Why don't it look like only
combinations of R prime over R
squared and GS?
HONG LIU: Sorry, I don't
understand what you're asking.
No, G5 is a
dimensional parameter.
5 dimension Newton
constant had dimensions 3.
So whatever dimension here,
some [? other ?] dimension
there would be
compensated by R5.
But you always have
3 dimension left.
So this is a dimension
3 number, yeah.
Any other questions?
Good.
OK, so then this
concludes our discussion
about string theory
in AdS 5 times S5.
As I said, there's not
much to talk about it.
And so now, let's look
at the other object,
which is the N equal
to 4 super-Yang-Mills
theory, which is the other
side of the equation,
of the duality equation.
OK?
So in this case, we have
a lot to talk about it.
We, in principle, have
a lot to talk about it,
but we won't have time.
So we will also not
talk much about it.
So we are only mentioning
a few essential things, OK?
So the field content, say, of
a N equal to 4 super-Yang-Mills
theory, which we
already learned,
which we already learned
from the [INAUDIBLE] theory
on the D3-brane is that you
should have a gauge field.
And then you have a 6 scalar
field, because 1 into 6
transverse direction
over the D3-brane.
OK, you have 6 scalar fields.
And then when you include
the super symmetric center,
in the super string,
then they actually also
the massless of fermions.
So this is 3 plus 1 dimension.
OK?
So in 3 plus 1 dimension, you
can represent the fermions
conveniently by two components,
for example, two component Weyl
fermions.
They it turns out there
are 4 such Weyl fermions.
So A will go to 1 to 4.
So alpha is a spinor indices.
And A just neighbor
different spinors.
So altogether, you
have four spinors.
OK?
And so this is, essentially,
the field content
of the N equal to 4
super-Yang-Mills theory.
So we would not worry
about the fermions.
So but I'm just mention
here for completeness.
So if you have a
U(N) gauge theory,
if you have a U(N)
guage theory, say,
for the N D3-brane,
then all this,
all this field is in the
of the [INAUDIBLE] of U(N).
In other words, each of
them is an N by N matrix,
is N by N Hermitian matrix.
OK?
So each of them
can be represented
by Hermitian matrices.
So altogether, yeah, yeah--
so let me not write it.
Let me just say it in words.
So altogether, you
have 8 [INAUDIBLE].
You have 8 bosonic
degrees of freedom.
Because for the
photon, you have 2.
For photon, you have 2
[INAUDIBLE] degrees of freedom.
And here, 6 scalar field,
you have 8 [INAUDIBLE]
degrees of freedom.
And for the fermion,
you can also
count that the 4 Weyl spinors
actually have 8 [INAUDIBLE]
degrees of freedom.
So altogether, you
have 8 N square.
Each of them is
an N by N matrix.
So you have 8 N squared, say,
[INAUDIBLE] bosonic degrees
of freedom, and eight 8 N
squared for mionic [INAUDIBLE]
degrees of freedom.
OK, for the--
AUDIENCE: Why would
we have 8 fermions?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: We have 8 fermions?
HONG LIU: No, we
have 4 fermions,
but each fermion have
some spinor component.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK, OK.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Where did
the number come from?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Where did 4 fermions?
HONG LIU: That come
from a calculation.
This I cannot explain here.
This, I can only
quote this fact.
It's just that if you work out
the theory on the D3-brane,
then [INAUDIBLE] there's
4 Weyl fermions, yeah,
which we did not go through
that, because we did not
do super string.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Should this come
from the fact that it's where
[INAUDIBLE]?
Symmetry?
HONG LIU: Yeah, it's come
from the super symmetry.
Yeah, come form the string
theory, super string theory.
So in our discussion, we
only discussed bosonic part.
We never had time to discuss
for mionic part, et cetera.
So let me now mention one
important point, which
I think is-- I hope
is self-obvious,
self-evident to you.
It's that this U(N)-- actually,
there's a U(1) which decouples,
which U(1) decouples,
just actually,
let me just write down the
Yang-Mills theory first.
So let me write down the
So you can write down the
Yang-Mills theory, which we are
actually wrote it down before.
Let me only write
down the bosonic part.
So essentially, just given
by Yang-Mills coupling trace.
And this is a covariant
derivative acting
on the scalar, standard
covariant derivatives.
And the I and the
j are all summed.
OK?
So I and the j are all summed.
So this is the Lagrangian,
then plus the fermionic part.
So this is the bosonic part,
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are fermions
coupled through 5 fields?
HONG LIU: Yeah,
they're all coupled.
They're all coupled.
AUDIENCE: How do they couple?
HONG LIU: Standard
[INAUDIBLE] coupling.
Yeah, so the key, so they couple
through a particular coupling.
The hosting, it just can show
to have a single coupling.
In principle, if you
have so many fields,
you can have many, many
different possible couplings.
You can have one
coupling between them,
one coupling between
them, et cetera.
You can have different
components, but
and self-couplings, et cetera.
And under the key of N
equal to 4 super-Yang-Mills
theory is that every coupling,
they equal up to some constant,
up to some constant
factors, which is precisely
give you the supersymmetry.
Anyway, so I think
it's obvious to you
that you have a U(N)
Yang-Mills theory that the U(1)
part decouples.
OK?
OK, you unplug the couples.
So U(N), you can
always decompose it
into SU(N) times U(1).
Under the U(1)
part, [INAUDIBLE].
So each A, each field
is N by N matrix.
And the U(1) part
is the part which
is proportional to
the identity matrix.
And the SU(N) part is
the part which given
by N by N trace this matrix.
And so the U(1) part is
proportional to the identity
matrix.
So but you can immediately
see from here, anything which
is proportional to
the identity matrix
all the commentators
will vanish.
OK?
So essentially, U(1)
part is a free theory.
So U(1) part is a free theory.
Yeah, if this is
not clear to you,
you can easily convince
yourself afterwards.
And this is also
where-- this is also
physically clear from
the point of view,
thinking that this is
coming from the D-branes.
Coming from the D-brane,
you have, essentially, you
have N D-brane together.
And this Yang-Mills
theory essentially
describes the low energy
dynamics of D-branes, brains,
so how all these N D-branes
interact with each other.
But no matter know how
they [? co-communicate ?]
[? interact ?] with each other,
there's always a center of mass
motion.
Does not depend on their
internal structure.
And that central mass motion
essentially is just this U(1).
And the central mass
motion always decouple.
OK?
So U(1) decouples.
And you can do the
check from here.
A U(1) decouples.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HONG LIU: Good.
So now let me-- so the
interacting part is just SU(N).
OK?
The interacting
part is just SU(N).
So now, let me say a
few words regarding
the properties of the theory.
So first, it's that this theory
has N equal to 4 supersymmetry.
OK?
So this is another
important remark.
This is just explain the
name, just explains the name.
So in supersymmetric
theories, so you
have a transformation between
boson and the fermion.
OK?
You have some-- the theory is
invariant on the transformation
between boson and fermion.
So on the [? side of ?]
transformation,
the [? conserved ?] charge, so
for [INAUDIBLE] transformation,
then you have loss of charge.
[? For ?] [? such ?] [? as ?]
transformation and loss
of charge can be
described by a spinor.
OK?
So normally, we say N
equal to 1 supersymmetry
if the super charge is
given by a single Weyl
spinor in 4 dimension.
So N equal to 4 means
that the total number
of such [? conserved ?] charge
is actually given by the 4 Weyl
spinors in the 4 dimension.
So it doesn't
matter, so these have
a number of supersymmetries.
OK?
And also, if you know a
little bit of supersymmetry,
then this is actually
the maximally allowed,
the supersymmetry
in 4 dimensions,
for [INAUDIBLE] field theory.
So this is actually maximum
allowed supersymmetry.
But this will not
be important for us.
OK?
But this will be.
But the next point will
be very important for us.
It's that because of this
theory is so symmetric,
so G Yang-Mills coupling, its
dimensionless, classically.
OK?
Because this is a 4 dimension,
the Yang-Mills coupling
is dimensionless, classically.
And the same thing with
our own QCD, our own QCD
coupling this
dimensionless, classically.
But then quantum mechanically,
then the coupling actually
changes with the scale, OK,
because over the quantum
corrections, et cetera.
So generic coupling
changes with scale.
But N equal to 4
super-Yang-Mills theory
is special.
But this actually, this
Yang-Mills coupling
does not change with the scale,
even at the quantum level.
So the quantum
level, this remains,
so dimensionless coupling.
So using the technical
term, for those of you who
have studied the QC
Yang-Mills theory,
is that the beta function at
the quantum mechanical level,
the beta function
for G Yang-Mills
is actually 0, which means
you can really treat this G
Yang-Mills as a parameter, as
a dimensionless parameter, even
quantum mechanically.
OK?
So this is a genuine parameter.
In contrasting our QCD,
there's no such parameter.
OK?
In QCD, we only have a scale.
There's no parameter.
Good?
So any questions
regarding these?
AUDIENCE: But you
said you wouldn't
know the coupling [INAUDIBLE]
coupling because of
[INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That means
this is not [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: No, it's not.
No, in the--
AUDIENCE: It's not [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: In QCD, the Yang-Mills
coupling is not the parameter.
It's not the
dimensionless parameter.
AUDIENCE: OK.
HONG LIU: It translates
into a scale.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
HONG LIU: It translates
into a scale.
AUDIENCE: So--
HONG LIU: It translates
into a mass scale.
AUDIENCE: Yes, but can we
find a massless parameter
in [INAUDIBLE] like this?
HONG LIU: No, because the beta
function is nonzero there.
AUDIENCE: Ah.
HONG LIU: Yeah, yeah because the
beta function is nonzero there.
OK?
And also because of this,
the beta function is 0.
This theory is actually
conformally invariant,
theory is actually
conformally invariant.
OK?
So which we'll normally call,
say, it's a conformal field
theory, because it's a CFT.
So one way to understand this
is because of the beta function
is 0, essentially, the
theory does not have a scale.
So theory classical scale,
invariant quantum mechanically
remains scale invariant.
And then you can show
that there actually
is a little bit more generous
conformally invariant.
So let me say a little
bit about the-- are people
familiar with the concept of
the conformally invariant,
or conformal?
AUDIENCE: No.
HONG LIU: No?
OK.
Yeah, so let me say a few
words about the conformal.
So conformally invariant
means that the theory
were under the conformal
transformations.
OK?
So let me say a few words on
the conformal transformations.
So conformal transformations
are the following.
Say, suppose your
spacetime metric
is given by some G mu mu.
So the conformal
transformations are those
coordinate transformations.
OK?
You go from x to x prime.
So that under such a
transformation, your metric,
the transformed metric is
related to the original one
only by an overall scale factor.
OK?
So if lambda is
equal to 1, then this
is what we called
earlier isometry, which
leave the metric invariant,
will be isometry.
And if you leave
the metric invariant
after your overall
scale factor, then this
is called the conformal
transformation.
OK?
And for the Minkowski spacetime,
for Minkowski spacetime,
actually, I can just
even use this thing here.
Yeah, maybe let me--
yeah, let me erase here.
So for Minkowski
spacetime, say if the G mu
mu is equal to [INAUDIBLE]
mu mu-- suppose this
is a d dimensional
Minkowski spacetime-- OK?
Then you can show--
you can just work
how to solve this
equation, work out
all possible such
transformations.
OK?
And you can show that
conformal transformations
are the following.
First, they are the
standard isometry,
which is the translation,
because the translation does
not give you lambda 1.
And then you have a
Lorentz transformation,
which also give you lambda 1.
OK?
And they you can have a scaling.
Of course, if you
scale your coordinate
with some factor,
then, of course,
the metric will only
change by overall factor.
So this is a translation.
So this is s Lorentz symmetry.
And this is scaling.
And then we also
have something what
we call a special
conformal transformation.
So this is for-- OK?
And the b, again, is
some constant parameter.
OK?
And also for the
discrete transformation,
also, you can have a discrete.
Also you can have a discrete
transformations inversion.
You [? said ?] x prime mu equal
to x mu divided by x squared.
OK?
So these are all
the transformations.
In general dimension, which
leave you metric invariant,
leave the Minkowski
metric invariant number
up to overall factor.
And the conformal
invariant theory
is a theory which
[? involves ?] transformations.
OK?
And so obviously,
a Yang-Mills theory
are always invariant on the
translation on the Lorentz
transformation.
But when the beta
function is 0, the system
does not have a scale.
Then it's invariant
on the scaling.
But typically, in general,
4 dimensional theory,
any theory invariant
on the scaling
is also invariant on
this special conformal
transformations.
So actually, the N equal
to 4 super-Yang-Mills
theory is actually
conformal theory,
OK, conformally
invariant theory.
So now, as part
of your p set, you
can actually see that this
conformal transformations
in fact [? have ?] 1
to 1 correspondence
with these isometries
of the AdS.
OK?
And this we will see later.
This is a part, important part
of the relation between AdS.
This is an important part
of this duality relation.
It's that the symmetry
have to be the same.
So you compare the two.
You can see that, indeed, they
1 to 1 correspond to each other.
So the conformal transformation
add together give you SO(d,2).
OK?
So this is the conformal group,
so-called the conformal group
in d dimension.
Then you get to the
[? SO(d,2). ?] OK?
And but in this theory,
there's actually also
global symmetry, because the
N equal to 4 super-Yang-Mills
theory come from the D3-brane,
which is a transverse space,
is the [? rotation of ?]
invariant.
So this actually our SO(6)
symmetry rotates different phi
i's.
So actually, there's also
global SO(6) symmetry,
which rotates phi i,
OK, and the fermions.
OK?
And then when you include
in the supersymmetry
then you get a huge
symmetry group.
It's normally called a
super conformal symmetry.
Anyway, let me just
write some notation down.
It doesn't matter.
So if you include the symmetry,
the full symmetry group
is what we normally call it.
So this is a super group, so
[? SU(2,2|4) ?] Doesn't matter.
So the bottom line is that the
N equal to 4 super-Yang-Mills
theory is the most symmetric
4 dimensional theory.
OK?
And almost-- no theory
has more symmetries than N
equal to 4
super-Yang-Mills theory.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So How do you know
that the [? flows are ?]
[INAUDIBLE]?
[? HONG LIU: Though ?] you can
classify it by solving this
equation.
You can classify it by
solving this equation.
AUDIENCE: But what's
the q [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: No, this
is just a notation.
AUDIENCE: A notation?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Any other questions?
So I can say a few words about
the conformal field theories.
But it's getting
a little bit late,
and I want to talk
about other things.
So let me just say it in words.
And then you can try to
read it in other places.
Because even if I just write
a couple formulas here,
it still won't
change you very much.
[LAUGHTER]
I won't teach you too much.
So important thing about
this conformal field theory
is that each operator, say
each local operator-- yeah,
you can classify local operators
by how they transform, say,
under these
conformal symmetries.
And then you can
associate, say, a dimension
to each operator,
related to how they
transform in these
conformal transformations.
And then you can also show
that the symmetry actually
dictates the 2-point function
and the 3-point function
of such operators.
And essentially, the structure
of the 2-point function
and 3-point function
are completely fixed.
But not higher point
function, but only
2 and 3-point functions.
Yeah, so that's essentially it.
Not much known, many things
are known about conformal field
theory in 1 plus 1 dimension.
And but higher
dimensions, yeah, other
than what I said, not much.
Not too much more
is known, yeah.
So any questions regarding this?
OK, so let me just summarize,
then we can have a break.
So we can summarize.
So let me just summarize what
we have done so far, and also,
with an important refinement.
So what we said is we
started with two picture.
One is D-brane with
some open strings,
and then some closed strings
can interact with it.
And then when we go to
the low energy limit,
then we get N equal
to 4 super-Yang-Mills
theory with, now, I say SU(N)
plus a decoupled U(1), and then
plus what we discussed last
time, a decoupled the gravitons
in the low energy limit.
So let me just write
E equal to 0 limit.
On the other side, we have this
[? pure, ?] [? geometric ?]
picture of the curved spacetime
produced by those D-branes.
So those curved
spacetime at infinity
behaves like just 10
dimensional Minkowski spacetime.
And then when you go to
the close to the brane,
then the space deforms
into the AdS 5 times S5.
OK, form into AdS 5 times S 5.
Under the low energy limit,
because 1 into-- we can see
the string theory in the
[? very ?] [? much ?]
[? tongue ?] this
[? throat. ?] OK?
So the low energy limit
is the string theory.
The one here when you're
take E equal to 0,
we get string theory
in AdS 5 times S5,
then plus decoupled graviton.
Here, also, here, when we look
at the geometry of the brane,
essentially, we have fixed
the location of the brane.
So essentially, we have fixed
to the center of mass motion.
But in principle,
you can allow, also,
the brane to move anywhere.
So here, essentially, there's
also a decoupled center
of mass motion.
OK?
So now, let's get rid of
this decoupled graviton.
Let's get rid of
this decoupled U(1),
or decoupled center
of mass motion.
Then what we get is the
fully interacting part.
OK?
So the fully interacting
part is so small
refinement than what
we said last time.
We said N equal to 4
super-Yang-Mill theory
with [? stage ?] group SU(N)
should be the same as the type
IIB string in AdS 5 times S5.
OK?
So, now, other side,
now, this is SU(N).
And more precisely, this is AdS
prime S5 in the Poincare patch.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The N
just to recall, is
the that N comes from the
amount of flux on the S5.
Is that correct?
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
So the N here related to
the flux on the AdS 5,
it's also related,
as we will see,
related the Newton
Constant, et cetera.
Yeah, we will see that, yeah.
OK?
So now, we can look at
this geometric picture.
OK?
We can look at this
geometric picture.
Then we observer
something interesting.
So this SU(N) group, let
me say, [INAUDIBLE] R 1,3.
OK?
On the 3, approximate
dimensional-- yeah,
let me write it better--
this SU(N) on the space,
on the Minkowski space, R 1,3.
So now, let's note.
Make a simple observation
based on the geometry of AdS
is that this R 1,3 is actually
the boundary of AdS 5.
OK?
It's essentially the
boundary manifold of AdS 5.
And the right hand
side, no matter
whether you do field
theory or string theory,
you can always do
dimensional reduction on S5.
You can always
decompose everything
on S5 in terms harmonics.
So essentially, the
right hand side,
because S5 is a compact
space, the right hand side
is a 5 dimensional
gravity theory.
OK?
So we actually now here see a
5 dimensional gravity theory.
Now, it's equivalent that your
4 dimensional theory [? lives ?]
on its boundary.
OK?
So this really can be considered
[? actually ?] realization
of holographic principle.
So actually, there are two
ways to think about it.
One way is to think from this--
so previously, we motivated.
Long time ago, we
motivated the duality using
two perspec-- [INAUDIBLE].
One is the
holographic principle.
Some gravity theory should be
[INAUDIBLE] to the [? theory ?]
living on this boundary.
And also, motivated that the
Yang-Mills theory in the gauge
group SU(N) or U(N), when you
do the [? large N ?] expansion,
then behaves like
a string theory.
OK?
So this could also be considered
as an explicit example
of that relation.
That this is a Yang-Mill
male theory, and then
turned out to be [INAUDIBLE]
to a string theory.
OK?
So now, if you look
at this statement,
you say, is this a coincidence?
Because I don't really see
somehow in this picture
not so much somehow how why this
Yang-Mills theory is actually
should be considered as living
on the boundary of AdS 5 times
S5, because the boundary
of AdS 5 times S5,
somewhere around here.
Yeah, I don't see some
Yang-Mills theory living
on there, OK?
So is this really
just some coincidence
that just happened to be that?
But actually, there's a
very important prediction
one can make if you
take this point of view.
Now, I can erase here.
Maybe I will do it here.
Yeah, but if you take
this point of view,
then there's a very important
prediction you can make.
Then there's a very
important prediction
you can make, and then
check whether that
has any chance of working.
So if you believe this
picture, then we can have
a [? non-trivial ?] prediction,
because AdS also have
[? a lot ?] of description
in terms of the global AdS.
Then let's say, what
happens if we put the string
theory in this global
AdS, which certainly, we
should be able to do,
because these two only differ
by some global structure.
OK?
And this is one part of that.
They only differ by
some global structure.
So if this is really true,
if this is not a coincidence,
then we can make a non-trivial
prediction is that N equal to 4
is a type IIB string in
global AdS 5 times S5.
So now, the AdS 5 we
take to be the global,
to take to be the cylinder.
That should be equal to the N
equals to 4 super-Yang-Mills
theory, which now, should
live on the boundary
of that cylinder, which
is our S3 times R. OK?
So this realization
will give you
a powerful prediction, which
in principle, you can check.
OK?
And, of course, if
this is a coincidence,
then there's no reason
why this to be true.
Because from the
brane point of view,
we cannot really do the sphere.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Why is [INAUDIBLE]?
Oh.
HONG LIU: So any
questions about this?
AUDIENCE: One question
[? on that. ?]
so when we derive the
right hand picture,
we impose that there's
some charge on the D-brane.
But on the left
hand side, it seems
that we-- [INAUDIBLE] a
the charge [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: No, the
charge is just reflected
in open string dynamics.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So by your right hand side,
we will have the charge.
HONG LIU: No, you
essentially have a charge.
But in that
description, you don't
need to introduce a charge.
Whatever charge--
AUDIENCE: If we impose charge
if the left hand side will never
be changed?
HONG LIU: No, no.
Just there from the side,
you just talk about strings.
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
HONG LIU: You don't talk
about the whatever charge.
The charge is a
gravity description.
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
HONG LIU: The charge don't
even arise in this picture.
I just have some strings.
I have some open strings.
I have some closed strings.
They interact with each other.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And did this picture
go to low energy means
it will appear as a charge of
the super-Yang-Mills theory.
HONG LIU: No, no, no, no, no.
No, no.
This goes [? in ?] [? order. ?]
You just super-Yang-Mills
theory.
Yeah.
Good?
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is this true?
HONG LIU: Yeah, this is true.
AUDIENCE: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
HONG LIU: And the yeah.
So that means this
is not a fantasy.
Yeah, this tells
this is a fantasy.
This is actually a
powerful realization.
This is a powerful
realization, yeah.
So let me before
conclude-- Let me
just quickly mention something
just in terms of semantics.
So I always say, type IIB
string in AdS 5 times S5.
So you may ask, does this
make sense to say such things?
Because if we think
this is really
as a quantum
gravitational theory,
so if you have a
finite string coupling,
then everything fluctuates.
And then why we specify
a rigid spacetime here?
OK?
Why do we specify a
rigid spacetime here?
So the way you should understand
the statement is the following,
is that indeed, if you,
say, consider the finite G
Newton, the finite
G string, then
the spacetime can
fluctuate a lot,
will typical be a deviate
from AdS 5 times S5.
But this AdS 5
times S5 specifies
it's asymptotic geometry of AdS.
It's asymptotic geometry.
It's the geometry of AdS very
far away near the boundary.
And essentially, this
can be considered
as specifying the
boundary condition
for gravity, the boundary
condition for the quantum
gravity.
So this, essentially, specify
the boundary condition.
Good, so let's have a
couple minutes break.
Then we will talk more
about the duality.
OK, good.
So let's start again.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
So now, let's move
to a new chapter.
So now, have we
established the duality.
So let's try to
understand the duality.
So let me call it
the duality toolbox.
And then we can try to use it.
So first, let me say some
general aspect on the duality.
Oh, I erased.
Oh, I should keep
that figure there.
Anyway, so the first
important thing
is so-called IR/UV connection.
So here, we see the equivalents,
say, from the AdS 5 gravity.
So we have some
AdS 5 gravity to go
to N equal to 4 super-Yang-Mills
theory in d equal to 4.
So from this direction, we
may consider as a realization
of the holographic principle.
OK?
We can consider this direction
as a holographic principle.
And then you may ask, from
the field perspective,
if we think from this
angle, why somehow,
this description of the field
theory have one more dimension.
So this is a 4
dimensional theory.
This is a 5 dimensional theory.
OK?
What does this actual
dimension does?
What does this x
dimension do, OK?
How do we understand
from the field theory
perspective somehow this
increase of one dimension?
OK?
So the answer turns out-- the
answer is actually very simple.
And it's already nice in a way.
The answer is already
in the way which
we take the low energy limit.
OK?
So remember, when we take
the low energy limit-- so
let me draw this figure
again-- in the gravity side,
and this is going
to R goes to 0.
OK?
So by studying the red shift
due to the curved spacetime,
we show that if you want
to go to low energies,
then you want to go to
smaller and smaller R. OK?
So you want to go to
smaller and smaller R
if you want to go to [? lower ?]
and [? lower ?] emerges.
OK?
So smaller r, and then
give you smaller energy.
So we use this
argument to decouple
this, the other factor.
We say, if you want
to go to low energy,
you take r go to 0 limit.
Then there are infinite
distance between them.
But the nice thing
about infinities
is that after you
go to infinity,
there's still infinite left.
OK?
So the same argument
also applies in AdS,
in the AdS part, after you
decouple the other stuff.
And the AdS part of this
argument still applies.
Still, the same thing happens.
The same red shift
argument applies.
So if you want to
go to low energies,
you want to go to smaller r.
OK?
And so this immediately tells
us that this actual dimension,
this r direction, it's precisely
the direction, which external
to the N equal to 4
super-Yang-Mills theory,
transverse to the N equal to
4 super-Yang-Mills theory.
So this [? immediate ?]
[? here is ?] this actual
dimension, this r, or in
this coordinate z-- remember,
in this z, z related to that
thing just by R squared divided
by r, so that r
related to that z.
So that the r goes to
0 limit, it tells you
that that r dimension,
r can be considered,
this actual dimension
can be considered
as representing the energy
scale of the Yang-Mills theory,
OK, or the energy scale
of the boundary theory.
So if you want to
go to low energy,
you go down [? farthest ?]
[? route. ?] OK?
This is a very, very
important point.
And this nice into many
phenomenon between AdS
and the CFT and
the disconnection.
Very important, and if you
have a good understanding,
it will give you lots
of good intuitions
in you understand the relation.
So let me just to elaborate
the argument again,
now using this metric.
OK?
OK, so now, we'll go over
this red shift argument again,
and to use this metric.
OK?
So again, so the key thing
is that the x mu, which
you t go to x appear
in this metric,
is defining the boundary unit.
OK?
So this defines-- so this
defined in the boundary unit.
So this is the unit we use
in the Yang-Mills theory.
OK?
So those coordinates are
defined in the boundary units.
So now, if we want to talk
about energies in some bulk,
say, the local proper
time, and the length,
and the total proper length
at some, say, at some z,
OK, so at some
location z in the bulk
is related by the
standard relation,
which we can read from there.
It say d tau should be equal to
R, so this local proper time.
Local proper time should be
equal to R divided by z dt.
And the dl, so
local length scale,
should be a proper length,
should be related R z times dx.
OK?
OK, just because of this.
You can just read it from here.
Locally, you can always write
this as a Minkowski metric
in d plus 1 dimension.
And then for the local
observer, and this
is the local time, local proper
time and local proper length.
OK?
And then this tells
you that you can easily
invert this relation.
This tells you the energy
we observe in the Yang-Mills
theory, was just energy
we measure in terms of t
should be related to the energy,
which we measure locally,
so all these relation,
local energy.
And length scale, now
d in Yang-Mills theory,
is related to the local
length scale by this relation.
OK?
So this is an inverse of
that because of the tau
and the [? energy. ?] This
is just the same as that.
OK?
Good?
So now, let's consider
the same bulk process.
OK?
So let's consider the
same bulk process.
Say, for example,
this process we
are sitting in this
classroom, say, supposing we
[? leaving ?] AdS.
Let's imagine that happens
at different values of z,
OK say, for the same bulk
process, at different z.
OK.
Then, of course, the E
local, the local energy scale
and the local length
scale would be the same.
OK?
So if we consider
the different process
at different z, the
same physical process
at different z, in terms of a
local observers, it's the same.
So E local and the d
local does not change.
OK?
But if you translate into
the Yang-Mills scale,
then you find now that the
corresponding Yang-Mills energy
scale now proportional
to 1 over z,
OK, because now, we
have fixed E local.
OK?
We have fixed E local.
We are changing z.
So now, you find at a different
location, now corresponding
to a different energy scale
in the Yang-Mills theory.
Say, the d Yang-Mills we
will [? portion it ?] to z.
OK?
And in particular, for
the same process as z
equal to 0, if we move this
process close to the boundary--
z equal to 0 means close
to the boundary-- then
the Yang-Mills energy, the
corresponding Yang-Mills
energy, actually
goes to infinity.
Under the corresponding
Yang-Mills scale,
actually goes-- distance
scale goes to 0.
So that means this is
a mapped to some UV
process in the
Yang-Mills theory.
OK?
And but if you take the
z goes to infinity, which
means you go to interior,
far away from the boundary--
so you go to infinity, far
away from the boundary,
go to interior-- then
this E Yang-Mills,
then the corresponding
Yang-Mills energy scale
will go to 0.
And the corresponding
Yang-Mills length scale
will go to infinity.
OK?
So this would corresponding
to the IR process.
So this will be a
low-energy process,
and [? much ?] distance
in the Yang-Mills theory.
So there, of course,
[? those run ?] into the IR
process in the Yang-Mills.
OK?
And [? this-- ?]
So normally, if you think
about the perspective
from AdS point of view,
when you go to the boundary,
means you've got
a long distance.
So from AdS point of view,
this is going to the IR.
OK?
And then when you go to the
infinity, z go to infinity.
You are going to the
interior in the bulk.
So roughly, it's not precisely--
[? if you ?] [? risk, ?] you
can think of this actually
going to the short distance
in the-- not really the
short distance, just-- yeah,
this name is not very proper,
but let's just call it the UV.
Just go into the
interior of the bulk.
So now, since you see an
[? opposite ?] process going
on, in the AdS will go to IR.
Then from the Yang-Mills
theory, corresponding
to going to the UV, but in
the AdS, you go to interior.
And then from the
Yang-Mills theory,
corresponding to go
to the IR low energy.
OK?
So here, we have something
like IR-UV connection.
OK?
In particular, I already
said in particular once.
[LAUGHS] So but I
don't have other words.
So in particular--
[LAUGHTER]
--if you really consider the
typical gravity process, OK,
so if you consider the
typical gravity process,
so not consider string
theory, just consider gravity.
Typical gravity process,
a classical gravity
processes, then essentially,
the curvature radius
defines your scale.
OK?
So that means that the
typical gravity processes,
the E local is of order 1
over the curvature scale.
And the typical length
scale in the bulk,
you can also see that it's
also the curvature radius.
So in these cases, if you
plug this into this relation,
then you can see that for
the typical bulk process,
you can really identify the
E Yang-Mills, essentially,
just with the radial
direction, OK,
because this product will be 1.
This product will be of order 1.
And then you can really just
identify the z, the inverse
z with the Yang-Mills energy.
OK?
So let me just say this
in the little bit slide
today, in the picture.
Maybe I'll do it here,
maybe just do it here.
So think about this
in the picture.
So suppose this is a boundary.
So this is the picture.
This is the picture, which
on the back page of the class
it said, if you consider
some process here,
which we draw a
cow, which I don't
know how to draw a cow here.
[LAUGHTER]
And at some distance,
say, here, some value
of z here, and similar process
as some other value of z,
then the corresponding
boundary image of them,
so this will corresponding
to a bigger guy.
And this guy will corresponding
slightly small guy.
OK?
Yeah, I hope you
understand the picture.
Yeah, [? so ?] the
further away, the same
process in the interior,
they corresponding
to a process with a larger
distance and a lower energy
from the field
theory perspective.
OK?
So now, let me
make some remarks.
Yeah, I did not
show it very well.
Is this clear what I
mean by this picture?
OK, good.
Yeah, a more fancy
picture is just
in the web page of the class.
So now, let me
make some remarks.
The first remarks is that
the AdS, if you, say,
calculate the volume
of AdS, so calculate
the determinant of this guy,
square root of the determinant
of the metric,
and then integrate
over the [? O ?] space.
Then you find it's divergent.
And particularly,
it's divergent because
of the infinite distance
in going to the boundary.
OK?
So often, we will, say, put
some cut-off, IR cut-off,
near the boundary,
say, rather than
let z go all the
way to z equal to 0.
We, say, we stop the space at
z equal to some [? epsilon. ?]
OK?
That's the procedure
we often do, just
as a mathematical convenience.
Because if you go all
the way to z equal to 0,
then this factor blows up.
And then many things
become tricky to do.
And then we often, in order
to get the finite answer,
we always put the z--
put the boundary at z
equal to some epsilon.
And epsilon's some
small parameter.
OK?
So and for example, this is
what you will do in your p set,
in one of the p set problem.
OK, when we try
to-- when you will
check this holographic bound.
And that's the trick
[? you're ?] [? ready ?]
to use.
So putting the IR
cut-off in AdS, at some z
equal to epsilon, then
from this IR-UV picture,
then translate in the boundary.
In the boundary, we introduce
a short distance cut-off,
or UV cut-off, say, at
some short distance scale,
say, [? data ?] x say or order
epsilon, or energy cut-off,
or UV energy cut-off
at, say, energy, say,
of order 1 over epsilon.
OK?
So this just a [? natural-- ?]
the reason this
goes 1 into a UV cut-off
because of this relation,
because of this relation.
When you cut-off
the space at some z,
then you can no longer
go to infinite energy.
You can no longer go to
infinite distance scale, OK?
And essentially, equivalently
providing a short distance
cut-off from that relation.
OK?
Is it clear?
And you will use
this in your p set.
OK?
So the second remark is that
here, we are considering,
so N equal to 4 super-Yang-Mills
theory, as we said,
it's a conformal theory.
Or it's a scale
invariant theory.
A feature for scale
invariant theory
is that there's no scale.
There's no scale means you can
have arbitrarily low energy
excitations.
OK?
So for conformal theory,
say, in R(1,3), there exists,
because of the scale invariants,
there exist arbitrarily low
energy excitations.
OK?
So from this IR-UV,
then this corresponding
to-- then this just
map to the z equal
to infinity region in the bulk.
OK?
So this map to the z equal to
infinity region in the bulk.
So it's a very good
thing that this z
equal to infinity region.
OK?
It's a very good thing, this
z equal to infinity region,
because otherwise, those
modes have nothing to map to.
So on the other
hand, even the theory
have a gap, on the
other hand, if, say,
if the corresponding bulk
spacetime, say, "ends"
at the finite proper distance,
OK, so important thing
is the following.
So let's take any point here.
Take any point here.
So this is some
reference scale, say.
Choose it as a reference
scale in the field theory,
because of this [? UV ?]
[? R ?] connection.
So now, we want to consider
arbitrary low energy scale
compared to this scale.
Then what you want
to do, then you just
you go to z equal to infinity.
And this, what is
actually hidden here
when you do this
argument, is actually
the proper distance going to z
equal to infinity is infinite.
And because when you do
this proper distance, yeah,
essentially, there's infinite
proper distance [? in ?]
go to z equal to infinity.
And then you can go to
infinite low energy scales.
OK?
But now, if you look
at the global AdS,
then take some interior point.
Then actually, you
can easily check.
When you go to the most interior
point, it's just ro equal to 0.
OK?
And that is finite
proper distance away.
So in some sense,
the spacetime ends
at the finite proper distance
in the radial direction.
OK?
In this case, if you apply
this, this will tell you that
the theory cannot have arbitrary
low energy excitations.
OK?
Is this clear?
Let me just say it again.
In this theory, in the
Poincare patch, in the bulk,
we can go to z
equal to infinity.
And that's infinite
proper distance away.
And using this UV
IR argument, that
translates to infinite low
energy process in the field
theory.
But now, let's consider what's
happening in the global AdS.
Just from the geometry,
we see something dramatic
happens, because now,
this is a cylinder.
And look at the metric.
You take finite
distance from some point
to go to the most center
point, which is rho 0.
So you no longer have
infinite distance to go to.
So if this argument
is consistent,
then this must be
due to a theory
without arbitrary low
energy excitation.
OK?
But this is, indeed, the
case, because according
to what I erased,
just before we break,
we say for the gravity theory
in the global AdS, that
should be due to a
Yang-Mills theory,
and the boundary
over here, which
is S times R. For any field
theory [? under ?] S-- again,
this is a compact
manifold-- then
there's a mass gap
from the vacuum.
And so this theory
actually have a mass gap.
OK?
So that means if the
corresponding bulk space that
ends this on finite proper
distance, the boundary theory
must have a mass
gap, and vice versa.
If the fields theory
have a mass gap,
which you cannot go to
arbitrary low energies,
and then the bulk spacetime
have to be end somewhere.
Otherwise, these
statements will not apply.
OK?
So consistency check
of that statement
is that this has to be true.
OK?
So in the p set,
you should think
through these for the
process over the field theory
on the cylinder.
OK?
OK, I think I will stop here.
Do you have any
questions regarding this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was somewhat
under the impression
that the global AdS
and the Poincare patch
were just different
coordinates for presentation
with the same thing, sort of?
So how -- would that be correct?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: I was
under the impression
that the global AdS
and the Poincare patch
are just different coordinate
charts on the same sort
of structure or [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So why do we have
infinite distance in one
and finite distance in another?
Is that?
HONG LIU: Figured out.
Figured it out.
And this is geometry.
You can just look at them.
It depend on how you
slice the spacetime.
Yeah, it's very easy to see.
Just see how you map one point
to the other point, et cetera.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
HONG LIU: But the important
thing, the important thing
is that the-- yeah,
I'll give you a hint.
So this z equal to
infinity can be considered
as a coordinate singularity
of that [? thing. ?]
so even though here
it's completely smooth,
but in here is like a coordinate
singularity because of this.
AUDIENCE: OK.
HONG LIU: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so that's why, actually,
to talk about theory on R3
and the theory on S3 is heading
[? on 2 ?] because the physics
are very different.
Because here, yeah,
because here, you always
have a mass gap.
And here, you don't.
And so that refract the
geometry very different.
The way you view the
geometry are very different.
AUDIENCE: So the
[INAUDIBLE] 5 [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: The [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Yeah,
yeah. [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: But if you
change this [INAUDIBLE],
then it's still N equal 4
super-Yang-Mills [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah, it
would be something else.
AUDIENCE: Then yeah.
HONG LIU: Yeah, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]